look guys i just to end this it's very
important as you saw there there's not
really
there's not really a case anyone can
make unless they want to talk about
archaeological
findings but the point of the matter is
this it is hypocrisy at the highest
level it is a double standard at the
highest level
when you have groups of people in the
west
new york conservatives alt-right
whatever you want to call them who
actually support
the state of israel and their call for
process of normalization
with israel you have even muslims voting
democrat because joe biden is apparently
better than
his alternative well actually he's not
in fact those muslims who voted for him
should be ashamed of themselves
knowing that he would be someone who
supports this course
i say very clearly that we should not
vote for
any of the political parties today labor
democrats the muslims should withhold
their vote
because you know why i'm not saying
because voting is cover or voting is
or that
we don't believe in this but what we are
saying is this
if we the the labor party in this
country
knows that muslims will vote for them
they they
don't have to work for it they don't
even have to work for it
the democrats are pretty confident that
muslims are going to vote for it
they don't even have to work for it but
we see the fact
that the democrats the democrats joe
biden
is saying that had a state of israel not
been there we'd have to invent one
this was his name stammer yeah first
name
what's his first name
yeah yeah this this fool he actually is
a zionist by his own confession
and he actually canceled one of the
meetings he had with muslim organization
because they're pro-palestine this guy
is no different
from what you have in the conservative
party therefore i say this clearly today
in addition to the social media policies
that we have in our directives
we should condemn those
parties the labour party and the
democrat party and we should withhold
our vote
we should never give them our vote
because they are supporting this
the wrong side on this on the struggle
we can't be selfish enough
to care about welfare benefits or jsa or
whatever you guys
we or our communities like in this
country welfare state
at the expense of our brothers and
sisters in palestine being bombed
with the blessing of the likes of joe
biden
and stammer we cannot vote for these
parties
we cannot we must make make them work
for if they want us to have to be very
clear on this issue it's a red line for
the muslim community
the palestine issue is a red line for
and i say this once and i'll say again
we will campaign against all political
parties
which do not candidly condemn the
palestine issue
and we are becoming a major demography
here we'll find in the 2021 census
now we're approaching the 10 mark so you
you mess around with 10 percent of the
vote
that in the current state will make or
break an election and they know it
based on first-past-the-post system so
we are actually
an important player in the voting and
what we will say is we will withhold our
vote
we will withhold it if you as a
political leader
are treating the muslim community and
the palestinian community in the way
that you're doing
and we will withhold our vote and we
will condemn joe biden
and condemn all of those who campaign on
his behalf from the muslim community as
well
and they should they should look again
at their strategies in america
they die as there because it's a wrong
strategy this idea of muslim
you've completely
that's why abraham said we are
disassociated with you
it's in the quran chapter 60 verse 7.
and with what you believe in
become we disbelieve in you
and between us is just enmity and hate
we say this to the zionist state
there's nothing but enmity and hate
between us we hate you
and we love to hate you and in fact we
just like you know actually i'll say
something i read his book
begin mahayan begin wherever his name is
it's called the revolt and he says in
the beginning how much he hates the
palestinians and how hate is a good
thing
well you know what we hate you too and
it's a mutual hate there's reciprocity
we hate you too to the zionists that are
bombing the children
and killing them and making people
suffer and not even by the way they're
not even
offering compensation have you thought
about that if they think about that
they've killed so many people 266
of them 30 children 20 women
75 women children and civilians you've
killed
hundreds of people and you don't even
want to compensate them
you've destroyed buildings and you don't
even want to rejuvenate them
you only rebuild their infrastructure
that shows that you are targeting them
all along
what do i do what what what do i assume
of a people
who know if you press a button 75
civilians will die including 30 children
would you press that button
if one lie think about that question for
a second
those israeli muslims criminals
armies when they were pressing the
button to detonate
and kill the children imagine knowing
that when i press this button
i have a 30 chance of killing a child
and they do it like and they do it
knowing that and in fact they've killed
2 000 such
children in the last 10 years you know
you're going to kill children
it's not fighting that's not fighting
you're punishing
you're punishing a military militant
group
with killing children because you know
why and this
i don't care what anyone says they think
because these are palestinian children
they are as good as cockroaches they are
as good as animals
i will lie i don't even believe that
while i believe if they saw a dog being
killed they'd feel more sorry for that
dog than they
feel sorry for the children of palestine
if they saw a cat being killed
they would feel sorry for that cat being
killed no and they would not feel sorry
they'll feel happy and joy as they
parade and enjoy seeing the children and
we're not going to forget it just
because there's a seafire
what do you mean ceasefire you've killed
266 people
we're going to continue shouting at the
top of our lungs
and we are going to continue putting
pressure on you we are a lot of people
here
with 50 million muslims in europe who do
you think you are
while who do you think you are don't
ever think that we're going to remain
quiet we're too big a number
pew says we're going to be one of every
three people in in 50 years
you're gonna you can't get rid of us
there's no genocide that can deal with
us
no nuclear weapon can get rid of us
we're in every city in the world
and not only are we in every city in the
world now in the age of
technology in the internet and social
media we are going to be influencing
every city in the world
and we are going to be dealing with the
oppression that you want to exact upon
us
because i tell you one thing one lie and
let everybody hear this
they tell us the muslim leaders
so-called muslim influentials
the scholars the clerics they say look
you need to find out why there's a
radicalization problem
why there are people blowing themselves
up why there are seven seven why there's
9 11
why there is the manchester bombing why
why why
osama bin laden when he wrote his fatwa
and i thought the early 2000s the first
thing he used
as ammunition for his jewish prudential
position
was the israel-palestine conflict
the first thing he used he mentioned it
in two fat was he wrote
he used the israel-palestine conflict
and he said the fact that america is
supporting israel
means that they are complicit in their
crimes and they are killing our
civilians
and therefore we should go and kill
their civilians that's the argument
do you want to know what the al-qaeda
argument is it's that
that is the argument they're killing our
civilians therefore let's kill theirs
tell me the difference between that
argument and the lieutenant argument
tell me the material difference between
that argument and the isi the isis or
the israeli argument
is israel is saying they're throwing
rockets at us they're determining bombs
therefore we need to bomb their most
densely populated areas
we need to kill their civilians
collateral damage
that's what they're trying to do as well
so osama bin laden
uses ammunition and when you have weak
words
fumbling pathetic weak
words from world leaders
like joe biden saying that israel has
the right to defend itself
you are putting your own populations
that danger you foolish people by saying
that
some fool now some muslim hypozealous
fool will take your words
and then contra distinct it juxtapose it
contrast it change it analyze it in
in in cooperation with they will
compare it with the words of joe biden
and what that narrative does
that political narrative it gives
complete currency to the terroristic
position
the radical muslim position then don't
come to us and say why are you
not de-radicalizing these people we're
trying to de-radicalize them and tell
them
actually we don't believe in killing
women and children in any circumstance
because the prophet said this and the
prophet said that and the quran says
this and the quran says
but when emotions get into the to the
picture
our argument which is a rational and
textual
and jewish prudential argument will not
be as strong as the emotional argument
of the terrorists and you're making
their argument stronger by siding with
israel so don't be shocked
to find some dumb guy some
monstrous muslim but blows himself up in
the next couple weeks
don't don't i'm not going to be shocked
if i see that i'm gonna expect it i'm
not going on trains
you're putting your own populations in
danger you're putting us in danger
by not taking a firm stance because
they've said okay well we're gonna trade
on
on civilians we're gonna kill your
civilians as well it's an alliance they
say
the leaders of this country and the
leaders of the west have a duty to their
own populations
and to us to make their position clear
don't have double standards when it
comes to terrorism do not
because that will make the world a more
dangerous place
and we're looking for world peace we're
looking for a situation where we've got
nuclear weapons seven billion people we
can't handle this stuff anymore
so this is what i say so many things
okay and therefore i conclude
my voice
wow i've shot it too much today
yeah yeah
[Music]